what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and ever since the very
beginning of the black clover story
back when hasta was first chosen by the
5-leaf grimoire the demons or Devils
whichever translation you prefer have
been the single biggest mystery in black
clover even now after like 250 chapters
of the manga Austin's own demon remains
a huge mystery and yet it turns out that
the demons have been pulling the strings
behind nearly every major events in the
story the entire elf saga was secretly
orchestrated by the kotodama demon
zagreb and after that saga finally
concluded the demons became an even more
prominent factor in the story with the
introduction of the dark triad and the
demon kingdom of spade after a very long
time we are now finally learning more
about the demons the nature of their
powers and their mysterious origins in
fact with the way that the story has
been shaping up I wouldn't be surprised
if the final arc and black clover has
already been heavily hinted at by Tabata
in this video I will break down
everything we know about the mysterious
demons their incredible powers and the
ultimate climax of the black clover
story a climax that will almost
certainly feature demons and demon magic
in a prominent role now you guys know
that we cover a lot of different series
on this channel and it's always fun to
see what our audiences favorite anime
are one of the ways that we can judge is
by the number of likes that our videos
get so if black clover is one of your
favorites be sure to absolutely smash
that like button and let's see if we can
hit 10,000 likes on this video also if
you're new to the channel or you just
haven't subscribed yet please consider
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications please be advised that
this video will contain black clover
manga spoilers beyond the anime I will
be referring to all the most recent
information so please proceed with
caution
you have been warned
there are a lot of interesting
unanswered questions and mysteries about
the demons or Devils in black clover but
perhaps the most interesting thing about
the demons at the current point in the
story is the fact that these creatures
come from another world sometimes
referred to as the underworld or on
alternate dimension after the segrete
fight Noel had a conversation with
Dorothy Unsworth inside of glamor world
and Dorothy actually revealed to Noel
that under normal circumstances demons
cannot manifest in this world since they
are from another dimension
they should not be appearing in this
world unless something is seriously
wrong we know that on some rare
occasions mages were able to use
forbidden magic to make a deal with the
devil in order to get more power for
example if a mage is willing to
sacrifice something and make a contract
in order to get power from the demons
they are able to temporarily break the
barrier that separates this world from
the demon world
but while the demons were a very rare
occurrence in the world of black clover
up until this current arc with austin's
demon and zag red being the only real
demons that we had met in over 200
chapters of the story with this latest
spade kingdom war arc it is clear that
the presence of demons is no longer a
rare occurrence in the black clover
world we have the dark triad and their
demons Meggie Kula Lucifer and whatever
Xenon's demons name is and then there
are all the dark disciples who are
clearly weaker than the dark triad but
who still rely on demon powers in her
conversation with Noel Dorothy said that
at this point in time something is off
with the world for some unnatural reason
the barrier between the world of the
demons and normal world is not as strong
as it was before and so as a result more
demons have been infiltrating this
dimension clearly this sudden influx of
demons is centered inside the spade
kingdom and is probably being
orchestrated by the dark triad but we
still don't know how exactly they
managed to weaken the barrier between
worlds and summon so many demons
however during his fight against Yami
Dante gave us some very important clues
about the demon world and what the
demons are ultimately planning to do to
this world dante tells Yami that he
intends to use his dark magic and
Williams world tree magic to open up a
magic channel called The Tree of Cliff
off if this magic channel is
successfully activated this world will
become linked to the demon world and so
theoretically an entire army of demons
could freely enter this world since
Dante clearly knows above this tree of
cliff auth and its ability to open
magical channels between worlds it is
likely that Dante and the dark triad
have been able to find other magical
channels in the past and that is how
they were able to summon their own
demons in the first place but it seems
that the magical channels they must have
used before were temporary and limited
so they couldn't use them to summon an
unlimited number of demons but
apparently with the help of dark magic
and world tree magic they could
theoretically create a more permanent
portal between worlds a portal that
would allow a much larger number of
demons to enter at the same time as
Dante is talking about his crazy plan to
summon all of these demons we see a
manga panel that seems to show us that
demons come in all sorts of shapes and
sizes and also that there are many of
them out there in the demon world we're
not just dealing with like three or four
creatures here we are potentially
dealing with an entire army of demons
that could destroy the entire world of
black clover but Dante's revelation
leaves us with two important questions
first why is it that these demons from
an alternate dimension are so anxious to
enter this world and second what makes
Yami's dark magic and william's world
tree magic so special and so essential
for opening this tree of cliff off the
first question is definitely a big
mystery we're not sure why the demons
seem so anxious to leave their own world
in order to enter the human world even
though that means giving up their own
bodies and being forced to possess human
vessels we have to assume that either
the demon world is a very bad place and
the
are just desperate to get out of there
or for some reason the demons just love
possessing and destroying humans in
particular and they can't do that unless
they find a way into the human world
the only thing that we really know about
the demons and their society is that
there is clearly a hierarchy among them
demons like segrete and Lucifer are
considered to be higher ranked demons
while demons like oz does anti-magic
demon are considered to be lower ranked
demons from his conversation with Dante
we know that Lucifer seems to have no
idea who austin's demon is implying that
austin's demon wasn't any sort of big
shot back in the demon world and Lucifer
also seems to imply that the higher
ranked demons possess the type of magic
that requires massive amounts of mana
for that reason an ability like anti
magic is considered to be pretty weak
sauce as far as Lucifer is concerned we
also know that austin's demon referred
to segrete as senpai so that further
emphasizes the point that osdas demon is
a lower ranked demon with that in mind
we could potentially assume that some of
these lower ranked demons are being
treated unfairly by the higher ranked
demons back in the demon world so they
decided to leave that world and come
here instead but that doesn't really add
up because clearly higher ranked demons
like segrete and Lucifer also decided to
come here since they are in the upper
ranks they are presumably not being
discriminated against back in their own
world so why leave your homeworld and
come here the only plausible
explanations that I can think of is that
either their entire world really sucks
and everyone who lives there is
desperate to leave or there is some sort
of threat inside the demon world a
threat that is too big even for higher
demons like Lucifer and Zug ready to
handle and so they would rather come to
this world out of fear they came here
because they were trying to escape an
even greater evil but if that was the
case then why would dante want to open a
portal between the two worlds that would
mean that this hypothetical greater
threat could also use the portal to come
here so despite my various speculations
we still don't know why exactly the
demons are so interested in leaving
their
own world and coming here all we can do
is guess at least for now it might just
be something as simple as their world
sucks and the human world is more
interesting the other mystery is why
Yami and William and their magic
attributes are so special
we know that Yami's dark magic is
extremely rare and that he was one of
the only people whose magic had a
serious effect on zag red and we also
know that William even though he lost
the fight against xenon was still able
to use his world tree magic to heal like
half of the Golden Dawn squad at once
after they were laid out by Xena
so clearly William's magic does have the
potential to counteract the actions of
demons we also know that the demons are
closely connected to forbidden magic
back in chapter 2 - 1 charlotte implies
that forbidden magic gets its power from
the demon world itself and as a result
forbidden magic interferes with the
nature of the world and the nature of
life so could it be that Yami and
William were somehow affected by
forbidden magic at some point in their
lives and that is why their own magic
has a special effect on the demons we
know that William had a magical curse
placed upon him so maybe that's the
forbidden magic angle but what about
Yami in previous videos I speculated
that Yami might actually be from another
world we know that he is from the Land
of the Rising Sun which is a land that
we still haven't directly seen in the
world of black over we only know about
it through Yami at this point we are all
assuming that Yami just got lost at sea
and ended up in another country but
could it be possible that while he was
lost at sea Yami somehow passed through
a magical portal perhaps a portal
created with forbidden magic and ended
up in a totally different world
perhaps Yami's Land of the Rising Sun is
actually the real Japan from our own
world and so Yami is actually a normal
guy from like Edo era Japan who got a
sick ID to a magical world the world of
black clover if this were the case then
it would explain why Yami's dark magic
is so rare and so unique and why it is
effective against magic from other
worlds because Yami himself is from
another world however that is just
speculation at this point as far as we
know the Land of the Rising Sun could
exist within the world of black clover
just somewhere far away from the clover
kingdom so what does all of this
information that we have on the demons
their powers and their true intentions
actually tell us clearly there is still
a lot that we don't know about the
demons but what we do know so far tells
me that the final arc of black clover
the ultimate climax of the entire story
is likely going to take place inside
this mysterious demon world / dimension
if you think about it the entire story
really seems to be leading up to that
point these demonic creatures just keep
coming into the human world and causing
massive problems and they've been doing
it for hundreds of years eventually and
especially if Dante succeeds in opening
a portal between the two worlds our
heroes will have no choice but to deal
with the problem at its source the only
way to stop the demons from constantly
pouring into this world is to stop them
in their own world before they ever have
a chance to come here so I am thinking
that yes at some point asta the black
balls and everyone else will have to
physically venture inside the mysterious
demon world that would give Tabata the
creative freedom to bring a whole new
fantasy world to life and it would give
us an opportunity to finally learn more
about the demons their origins their
society and their culture and what
better way to finally reveal more
information about Austin's demon then to
include his backstory as part of a wider
demon world arc the thing with every
single battle Shonen and with black lore
in particular is that the story has to
keep raising the stakes in terms of
power since the heroes are constantly
getting stronger and unlocking new
powers the villains also have to keep
getting stronger in order to pose a
worthy challenge to the heroes at this
point in the story the dark triad and
their demons are extremely overpowered
and they are definitely worthy
challengers for auste and everyone
but eventually once the dark triad is
finally defeated the question becomes
where can the story go from here if the
demons of the dark triad like Lucifer
are already higher-ranked demons then
who could possibly pose an even bigger
threat than them one way to get around
this would be with a demon world Ark
since we have so little information
about the demon world
we have no idea just how powerful some
of these demons inside that world could
be so an ark that would take our heroes
into the demon dimension would offer
infinite possibilities for introducing
new even more powerful demonic villains
and who knows maybe the demons who came
into this world even the most powerful
ones are just weaklings compared to some
of the demons who are still hidden
inside the demon world a world full of
unknown threats which make it possible
to raise the stakes higher than ever
before if there is a demon world or
personally I would definitely want to
see a demon world Ark and even if this
doesn't end up being the final Ark I
think that the demons themselves are
definitely the most interesting mystery
in black clovers so far but let me know
what you guys think do you think that
the final arc of black hole will involve
hasta and the rest of our heroes
physically traveling into the demon
world and do you feel like the rest of
the story has been slowly building up to
that very moment or do you maybe think
that the final arc will be something
completely different and if so feel free
to drop me a line down in the comments
and tell me what you think is going to
happen in the final arc if you enjoy
this video you want to see more black
clover content right here on the channel
please leave a like it really does help
and if you happen to be new to anime
uproar or you just haven't subscribed
yet don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of clicking the bell
and then selecting that option that says
all if you don't do that you are going
to miss a lot of our videos
it's just how YouTube works feel free to
also hit me up on Twitter and Instagram
at anime uproar I want to give a big
thank you to all of our anime uproar
patrons for making videos like this one
possible special thank you to baby
and a friend a disciples of Lord we go
himself and I can't forget all are the
one tear patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including in grata alone
Adam the world stealers the school bus
Tyson Quintino acquired respect Pat a
heffa Jonathan King deci D and Brandon
Ovilus finally big thank you to all of
our pro hero tier patrons including the
one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
at Jason Wilson Kings eldress Anatole
kazansky unhealth team Sparky 65 Rohan
Kapoor cricket XP Ted no Ted Salter Joe
Stanton very Gucci Elisha actor animal
as 69 Jessica Calif on he no kami and
water
Bonnie parks Zoey art 12 rasu Endora
Emperor otaku JCCC waka the coach and
Tendo if you enjoy our videos and you
feel that they provide value for you
please consider supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar gives you access to
our patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see us space cowboys
[Music]